I recently learned that Professor Hubert
drus the philosopher and outspoken
critic of the field of artificial
intelligence has died at the age of 87
he published a lot of philosophy and uh
did a lot of teaching but one of the
things he's best known for and most
relevant to this channel was his work on
artificial intelligence and its limits
uh so I'm going to talk about that a
little bit today and focus on one of his
arguments in particular so in the 50s
and 60s AI was the next big thing
uh computers were tackling problems
they'd never been able to approach
before people were very excited about
what was possible and artificial
intelligence researchers were confident
that true human level intelligence was
uh right around the corner their
reasoning was something like this
thinking consists of processing facts
using logic and rules uh what you might
call symbol manipulation you have some
things you know you know the
relationships between them you know the
rules of logic and you can use those to
reason about the world computers can do
this kind of symbol manipulation very
well and they're getting better all the
time so computers are able to think and
they're getting better at thinking all
the time dfus saw some problems with
this and one of those problems was that
a lot of human thinking doesn't seem to
boil down to symbol manipulation at all
it's only one of the ways we can think
it's perhaps the most Salient because
it's related to language and conscious
thought which is the part of the mind
that we're most aware of but actually a
lot of the processing seems to be happen
happening much lower down when you look
at something you don't think ah yes this
has four legs and a flat top and a back
so it's a chair and this thing has four
legs and a flat top and no back so it's
a table because I've learned the rules
of what a table is and what a chair is
and now I'm applying those rules no you
just look at the thing and you know that
it's a table the object identification
is done before your conscious mind is
even aware of anything and it's not like
your unconscious mind is doing this kind
of rules-based thinking in the
background it's much fuzzier than that
and what would the rules be for
identifying chairs anyway I mean do you
need a back do you need four legs or
like any legs at all I mean this is
still a chair is this thing is this or
this even something as simple as a chair
is really hard to pin down you need a
lot of rules and it would take a human a
long time to evaluate them and that
isn't how the brain works you can
imagine any of our ancestors who thought
hm well this thing has four legs but it
has a tail so my rules say that it's an
animal the pointy ears and sharp teeth
suggest it's maybe a cat and its size
suggests perhaps a lion or a tiger
looking at the stripes on the side I can
like you're dead before you're done
counting the legs so dfus thought there
were problems with the assumptions that
AI researchers were making about the
mind he saw that the model of cognition
that the AI researchers were using
didn't capture the complexity of human
thought and so their reasons for
thinking that computers could do the
things they claimed they could do uh
weren't very good and he went on to
publish some work including a book
called what computers can't do which
argued that a lot of the things that AI
researchers claimed computers would soon
be able to do were actually impossible
things like pattern recognition natural
language Vision complex games and so on
these things didn't just boil down to
symbol manipulation so computers
couldn't do them so how did the AI
researchers react to this philosopher
coming along and telling them that they
were foolishly uh attempting The
Impossible well they did the obvious
thing which is to ignore him and to say
unkind things about him there's a
wonderful paper called the artificial
intelligence of hubal dfus which I'll
link to in the dooblydoo check it out
back in the day before the internet you
know people had to do their flame Wars
on typewriters was a different time so
having dismissed him completely They
carried on trying to apply their good
oldfashioned AI techniques to all of
these problems for decades until they
finally had to admit that yeah it wasn't
going to work for a long of these
problems so about some things at least
dfus was right from the start but the
interesting thing is that since then new
techniques have been developed which
have started giving pretty good results
in things like patent recognition
language translation High complexity
games and so on the kind of things
driers said computers flatly couldn't do
people say that we moved away from this
good oldfashioned AI approach uh which I
don't think is really true we didn't
stop using those techniques at least on
the problems that they work well on we
just stopped calling it AI but the point
is the new techniques were what you
might call subsymbolic you could make a
neural network and train it to recognize
tables and chairs and tigers you can
look through the source code of that
system and you won't find anywhere a
single symbol which means legs or ears
or teeth or anything like that it
doesn't work by symbols in the way that
the logic and rules-based approaches of
the 60s do so ders was right that the AI
techniques of the time weren't able to
tackle these problems but the thing he
didn't expect to happen was computers
being able to use symbols to implement
these nons symbolic systems that can
tackle the problems so to oversimplify
the AI researchers said thinking is just
symbol manipulation computers can do
symbol manipulation therefore computers
can think and dfus said thinking is not
just symbol manipulation computers can
only do symbol manipulation therefore
computers can't think I don't think
either of those is really right one of
them underestimates what the human mind
can do do the other underestimates what
computers can do I think what I take
away from all of this is you can come up
with a simple model that seems to
explain all the important aspects of
some complex system and then it's very
easy to convince yourself that that
model fully covers all of the
complexities and capabilities of that
system but you have to be open to the
possibility that you're missing
something important and that things are
more complex than they seem now you
might say well both sides of this
disagreement made a similar kind of
mistake and they're both wrong I don't
see it that way at all though I mean
someone who says the Earth is flat is
wrong but someone who says it's a sphere
is wrong as well it's an oblate spheroid
it's bigger around the equator but then
it's not really an oblate spheroid
either they're perfectly smooth which
the Earth is not so you could say that
all of those views are wrong but some of
them are clearly more wrong than others
so at the end of the day can we make
computers do any kind of thinking that
humans can do some people think that now
that we have all these new approaches we
have deep learning and so on and we're
able to start doing the kind of
non-symbolic thinking that ders pointed
out was necessary we can add that on to
the rules and logic stuff and then we're
nearly done and we're going to ride this
current wave of breakthroughs all the
way up to True general intelligence and
maybe we
will but maybe we won't maybe there's
some third thing that we also need and
it's going to take us several decades to
figure out how to get computers to do
that as well maybe there's a fourth
thing or a fifth thing but I don't think
there's a hund thing I don't even think
there's a 10th thing I think we'll get
there sooner or later but I've been
wrong before so here's the Hubert dfus a
great thinker and a man well ahead of
his time was he right
overall probably too soon to tell but I
think he's truly deserving of our
admiration and respect for being loudly
and publicly less wrong than those
around him which is probably the best
any of us can hope for
just wanted to end the video with a
quick thank you to my amazing supporters
on patreon and I especially want to
thank Fabian consilio who sponsors me
for $10 a month I actually have quite a
few people sponsoring me at that level
but I thought I'd thank each one in
their own video though the waiting list
is getting kind of long now I think I
might increase the dollar amount on that
reward level to keep the wait times down
anyway I hope you enjoyed the behind
thes scenes uh PC build video I put up
I'm looking to have some more behind
the-scenes stuff going up fairly soon oh
and we hit a Target which means I can
get a new lens for this camera which
should really increase the uh quality
and range of what I can do here so thank
you again and I will see you next time